ils ont déjà la passion pour le jeu mais
avec les accomplissements de ses deux
visites et nice canadien tous les
espoirs sont permis scènes un peu oui
parce que je me dis que tu es ankara de
le faire aussi chez carat de le faire
quand j'ai commencé à l'âge de 6 ans
c'est vraiment intéressant puisque les
deux sont des vrais moi j'aime ce joueur
de tennis et un peu ce soit canadien
vers coups de raquette était un peu plus
vigoureuse surtout quand on sait que
leilani fernandez s'est entraîné ici à
montréal elle est de notre club en plus
salées canadienne alors c'est comme ça
nous apporte beaucoup de joie je trouve
que depuis ios au pognon a commencé et
félix aussi elle est là aussi on
commençait à gagner est avancé de tour
en tour les enfants sont comme le
motivait les petites filles m'ont dit
mais miel même aujourd'hui et me rend ce
soir les larges ou moins on joue je veux
être comme l'est la à 19 ans fernandez
73e au classement mondial a causé la
surprise aux internationaux des états
unis notamment en éliminant les osaka et
guerbert félix au gel et à s'aimer et
également dans le carré danse ce qui
laisse croire que le canada est en voie
de devenir une pépinière de joueurs de
tennis
c'est énorme c'est énorme les jeunes qui
vont être inspiré par ça va ça va être
vraiment incroyable à travers le canada
avec un travail rigoureux et assidu
rappelle le père de l'est la seconde
chance que les hommes
les présente parce que le travail est
très fort mal à développer son jeu son
style et elle a développé ses patrons de
gauche et que maintenant on est en train
de le voir en train de vraiment
bousculer un petit peu le circuit avait
quelque chose de nouveau ici midi
françois radio canada mon rêve